hi I'm Michelle hickner I'm here to talk
to you about a new paper we have in the
aiaa journal it's about data-driven
unsteady aeroelastic modeling for
control
so big picture we're going to take some
data where we predict coefficient of
lift and some measure of deformation of
a wing it's going to be a flexible Wing
we're going to turn that into a nice
interpretable model that's also low rank
and linear so it's good for control and
then we're going to go over some control
examples
so the reason that I care about models
like this is because I'm really
interested in insect flight or flight
for robots that are kind of insect scale
and as you can see with this butterfly
it's got significant Wing deformation so
we can't just use a rigid model and
expect it to work and also especially
for those robots we might really care
about how much deformation we're getting
so that we can limit it
also at these scales we start to care
about viscosity and so some of our
classical models need to be adjusted a
little bit
so let's talk about classical models so
this is thin airfoil Theory the very
most basic version
we've got an angle of attack so that's
how much the wing or the plate is
pitching against the flow
and then our coefficient of lift is a
nice non-dimensional way of talking
about how much lift Force we're getting
so thin airfoil Theory says okay in our
its most basic form 2 pi times the angle
of attack is how much is the coefficient
of lift
that's lovely it's obviously a little
bit too simple for most cases so
let's move on to theodorson's model so
this is a model developed in the 1930s
it's again predicting coefficient of
lift and we still have our nice little
two Pi lift slope it's still in there
now that slope is being adjusted for the
pitch point that's what a is in this
equation are you pitching from the
Leading Edge are you pitching from the
quarter cord
and that term Associates the two Pi lift
slope is still the quasi-steady term but
now we get some extra terms
now we get some added Mass terms and
those are associated with the angular
velocity and angular acceleration of
those pitching motions
so when a structure moves through a
fluid especially when it accelerates
through a fluid it can bring some of the
fluid with it and that's added mass that
you have to account for when you think
about the forces on the wing
and then we have this mysterious sea of
K term so that's theodorson's transfer
function it's a whole mess of vessel
functions I'm not going to show them to
you that's capturing the Wake vorticity
so this model is for a sinusoidally
pitching Wing nice harmonic motion that
K is reduced frequency it's capturing
the frequency at which the wing is
pitching
and C of K will tell you how much the
lift is attenuated or enhanced based on
that flapping frequency in the wake
vorticity
this model is great
as Grissom limitations in particular
that 2 pi lift slope is really
associated with inviscid flow and as I
mentioned with insects We Care somewhat
about viscous flow or about insect
robots
it's also for that sinusoidally pitching
with idealized planar wake but we want
to know what's going to happen when you
do arbitrary emotions not just
sinusoidal motions
also we really do have flexible wings
and there's only a certain amount you
can do with this model when as your
wings get more and more flexible
so I keep talking about viscosity why do
I keep talking about viscosity so this
is Reynolds number down on this axis
and it's capturing something
approximating to how much do you care
about viscosity and for big and fast
things viscosity might not matter so
that whale might not Banner so much but
as you get into the insect scales and
smaller or into the insect robot scales
you do start to care about viscosity
that's what this Reynolds number axis is
capturing
so here's the model it's a lot of terms
let's go through them one by one
so we're predicting coefficient of lift
and curvature so the curvature here is
our model our way of measuring
deformation but it could also be strain
or some sort of angle whatever works
best for your system
and we have some nice interpretable
coefficients in here and we're going to
talk about how we get those
let's go through them one by one that
orange term that your that's your
quasi-steady term
the upper line associated with
coefficient of lift for it that would be
your two Pi lift slope in a relatively
inviscid regime but as you get towards a
viscous viscous regime that coefficient
is going to change and because we get
this from data we're going to be able to
dial that associated with our system
and then our added Mass terms similarly
we've got these coefficient
acceleration and angular velocity and
they're also going to be adjusted for
that viscous regime because we're going
to get data from our system to build
them
and this whole Matrix has two rows so
you're going to get coefficients
associated with the coefficient of lift
and then you're also going to get these
coefficients associated with your
measure of deformation so you can see
how much each term contributes to each
are theodorson's transfer function is
still brought in here it's no longer
explicitly a bunch of vessel functions
that's your wake vorticity and now it's
also going to be your bending transients
because we're also modeling deformation
not just coefficient of lift so that's
our C Matrix there
so how do we get these
it's actually a great nice
straightforward procedure addition
multiplication there's no hidden deep
neural net hiding in here because we
want not just the model to be
interpretable but also how you get there
so the first thing we do is we pluck off
the added Mass terms
on the bottom we've got the maneuver we
do in order to build this model so we do
a little short pitch up
an angle of attack and that's the
equivalent of a nice little impulse
in angular velocity and then you also
got these nice little Peaks and angular
acceleration so you have clear peaks in
those
at the top we've got the coefficient of
lift and the curvature data associated
with this maneuver so we do the maneuver
we take a Time series data and that's
how we're going to build our model
so
wrong direction there we go
that peak in angular acceleration you
see circled in purple
that's the point of Maximum acceleration
so we want to get our coefficient
associated with acceleration from there
we're going to grab the data from those
two points at coefficient of lift and
curvature and that's how we're going to
get that coefficient
we can do the same thing with angular
velocity take the peak angular velocity
and at the time series the point where
we're there we're going to grab those
points and those are going to be turned
into our angular velocity
coefficient so those are our two added
Mass coefficients and we pull them from
the times of Maximum acceleration and
maximum velocity
those orange arrows over there those are
telling you that if you go to the very
end of the time series when everything's
settled down no more wibbly wobblies
that's where we're going to get our
quasi-study coefficient which makes
sense because we need it to be
quasi-steady if I showed you the data
from there it would be very flat and
boring because that's what we need for
quasi-study
and then
all the other stuff so we are going to
use era eigen system realization
algorithm to get the a matrix the B
Matrix and the C Matrix that captures
all of the transients and the Wake
vorticity so this is the bending the
shedding of vortices
if you aren't familiar with era I
recommend watching Steve rutton's videos
on era to catch up on that and you can
also get more details about the exact
ways to build this model from our paper
so the next step how do you choose your
model rank so
those latent States X we had in our
model we have to choose how many of them
we want and we want as few as possible
so that we can have nice fast real-time
control you need to be able to compute
what's going to happen in the system
as fast as it's happening
so we're going to go from Ace if you
were simulating a big cfd
with millions of different
nodes now we want to go down to just a
few so in this model we could choose
from the Hinkle singular values similar
to how you choose singular value cutoffs
truncation in any other system and you
might choose somewhere you know in this
range because you're going to get
diminishing returns as you add more
uh more States from there
I also like to use a test maneuver it
lets me tell it shows me not just what
the error is with that
but also
exactly what's going on it helps me
understand what's happening in the
system a little bit better as I cut off
States
so you see a little dotted black line
we've got coefficient of lift up here
we've got curvature down here the dotted
black line is essentially reality it's
our big full-scale model that we're
comparing this to and that we built the
data off of but off of a different
maneuver
hiding in the back it's easier to see in
the deformation you've got a dark red
line
and it's very straight
it's capturing
that very low rank Behavior so that's
our Rank 4 model
but it's really not capturing any of the
bending it doesn't seem to be capturing
any of the Wake vorticity so we can tell
that's not a good model for us
that blue line so that's the rank 6
model
for coefficient of lift and this is one
reason it's really important to also
have deformation in your model is that
you want to be able to realize wow I'm
really missing some things if I stick
with that state
and you can see that it's tracking this
red line it has
maybe one bending mode or one Vortex
shedding mode but it's really missing a
slower mode over here
and so we're not quite there yet and we
get to rinkate we're not perfectly
tracking
our full order model but we're doing a
pretty good job we're doing close enough
that that our feedback control will
easily be able to handle any remaining
errors
and similarly in coefficient of lift
we're doing great so rank eight that's
great nice accuracy we're happy
this model is more than just accurate
let's talk about how you interpret what
comes out so we gave it those
interpretable coefficients what do we do
with them so this is just looking at
that same test maneuver we pitch up we
hold we pitch down and that gives us a
nice little bit of acceleration it gives
us some nice quasi-steady behavior so
that's why we use this test maneuver but
the test maneuver might be different in
different situations
at the very top we're just showing that
same data you saw it's tracking it
really nicely this is actually a rank 9
model rather than an eight but it's
still doing it's doing great
here's the fun part
Okay so we've got coefficient of lift
over here we've got curvature over there
and now I've taken this upper curve and
I've cracked it apart into each of the
each of the contributions from the angle
of attack the angular velocity the
angular acceleration and the remaining
transients and bending in that c Matrix
so
in coefficient of lift
what all of these curves are kind of
similar sizes that tells me that all of
these contributions matter
in deformation I think we get really
interesting results so in deformation
that kind of speed bump looking curve
that's tracking our angle of attack
that's the contribution to deformation
from the angle of attack no angular
velocity no angular acceleration and it
is very important and then the second
most important is that green curve
that's our bending modes and our
transients and we'd expect that from
deformation that our bending modes are
important
but that's going to give us information
when we design our control objectives
that our deformation is really going to
track our angle of attack it doesn't
care so much about acceleration which
wasn't intuitive to me I might have
expected that our deformation would
really move around as I jerk this thing
around but no it really tracks angle of
attack mostly
so let's see how we can use this
I'm going to give you some control
examples this is just kind of our basic
control architecture we're going to be
running a full order model so this is
our full order system all of the
non-linearities but we're going to do
all of the prediction for the feedback
using our linear rank 9 model so our
linear State space low rank model we're
using model predictive control that's
what's in this purple box because we
wanted to be able to use constraints on
curvature so it wouldn't bend too far
we're actually going to try this out
with both constraints and references on
curvature and then we give a reference
coefficient of lift so we want it to
track a certain coefficient of lift
and we use the cost function to say how
much do we care about one versus the
other
so here's an example in this one we are
not giving any
weight to curvature we're only giving a
weight to lift we only care about the
lift so that light gray in the
background that's our reference the
coefficient of lift is supposed to be
tracking it and what a beautiful job it
does that's great but our curvature is
going to take a long time to kind of
swaying down and lots of vibrations in
your system definitely lower your
service life
okay so now we've added a green curve to
that same plot we saw before
so we've added a reference curvature
we're saying curvature go to zero
after we're done with our little
maneuver
we've given it a trade-off saying I care
about curvature sum and I care about
lift some and now we do see our lift
tracking is a little bit worse we had to
give up something but our curvature
tracking we managed to quash those
vibrations much faster which if you're
looking to extend service life might be
worth the trade-off in a little bit
bumpier lift
having the model be interpretable helps
us avoid bad situations like this yellow
curve in this red curve
so this is a similar test maneuver this
is a pitch up hold pitch down
but we've done it at a couple different
speeds to capture how much of the
quasi-steady contribution we're getting
so if you go too fast
your coefficient of lifts simply can't
track the reference so this light gray
is our reference you can look at that
first sharp curve the yellow curve just
can't quite make it there okay that's a
pretty normal situation if you go a
little slower this orange curve oh
beautiful it tracks it but we've put in
a constraint on the curvature we've said
don't bend too much at the Leading Edge
because we don't want too much stress
there maybe our plate could break or a
wing could break
and so if you put a constraint on
curvature and
increase the angle of attack so down
here I've showed the angle of attack
necessary to achieve
this
so the longer you want to hold your
higher coefficient of lift the more your
angle of attack has to increase because
its short Maneuvers it's really relying
on angular acceleration
that's the added Mass Effect but the
longer you hold it the longer it has to
pitch further and further up and as we
saw from our interpretal coefficients
the deformation is really going to track
that angle of attack so you want to be
able to do control objectives that you
can get away with mostly with accelerate
using angular acceleration and not just
hold your ring at higher angles of
attack
these were nice test Maneuvers to
demonstrate that but sometimes systems
are much trickier than that and so
having interpretable coefficients being
able to just look at a matrix and say oh
this number is Big that means that I'm
going to have to be able to avoid this
situation makes planning your controls
so much faster there's so much less
sorting out what's going on with the
physics
so let's sum up what we've talked about
we talked about a method to make a
linear low rank model it's for an aero
elastic system with a flexible wing
and it's nice and quick for control it
accurately predicts lift and deformation
and the reason it's accurate is because
we're getting it from data
so you can check out all the details in
our paper here and thank you for
listening